[Musique]
je veux dire je l'aï poussé la
chansonnette en ligne home mignonne
toute petite copine rebecca qui va fêter
ses jeunes deux ans demain un deuil clin
d'oeil j'étouffe rire attractive bien
que t'as jamais
[Musique]
j'aime bien c'est une journée très
froide et viticole ça remonte à quand la
dernière fois qu'on a été réuni je tiens
vraiment avoir l'impression que c'est un
week-end normal je veux un endroit qui
me donne envie d'entrer gaiement dans la
cinquantaine
l'âge n'est qu'un simple chiffre toi tu
dirais que tu as quel âge qui est plutôt
passé pour voir et baisers j'ai pas
encore ma propre voiture
mais gerber je vous ai préparé un
programme une somme de vue d'ensemble de
toutes les choses qu'on va faire minute
par minute alors ici nous avons dit aux
cornes à la lavande n'y en a pas arraché
dans la chimie
3 ça moi je me suis fait une molly à
l'université mais elle est retournée
avec son copain vous vous faites un week
end entre filles c'est ça mais quelles
que soient les propos vous entendre et
c'est probablement ce que l'autre
personne a toujours ressenti et c'est
l'alcool qu'il fait parler ses week-ends
et un fiasco
il ne m'aime pas planifié un
anniversaire ça si tu pouvais seulement
lâché prise tout ce passait pour le
mieux
tous passerait pour le mieux vous croyez
que balancer le programme par la fenêtre
ça fait partie du programme
je crois qu'on le saura jamais
et
[Musique]
ici on peut même pas survivre à un
week-end ensemble bah alors je suis
complètement paumé c'est le toubib ces
femmes-là filet connaît depuis plus de
20 ans j'aimerais envoyer celle-ci
sphère politique gilles me faire c'est
le genre de réaction que l'intimité pan
gendrier
celui-ci est bon ça s'appelle comment du
vin blanc je suis super fan
[Musique]